Je m'appelle Cécile Gallien,
Je suis maire de Vorey-sur-Arzon.
C'est une commune de Haute-Loire
et je suis très attachée
à ce beau département
qui est dans le Massif central,
qui est situé
entre le Puy-de-Dôme et l'Ardèche.
J'y suis maire depuis 2008.
Je suis aussi vice-présidente
de l'Association des Maires de France,
en charge de la commission
des communes et territoires ruraux.
J'ai été également
conseillère départementale
de la Haute-Loire
et je suis saxophoniste dans la Banda de Vorey
depuis que je suis en âge
de jouer du saxophone ou de la musique,
c'est-à-dire l'âge de six ans.
J'ai commencé à faire
des études d'économie,
à la faculté de Saint-Etienne.
Et puis j'ai eu
un DESS d'aménagement du territoire
et ça a été ma passion.
Et c'est toujours ma passion.
La politique me plaît parce que déjà,
au niveau familial,
on écoutait beaucoup la télé,
les échanges des uns des autres.
Je suis centriste,
on va dire de naissance.
J'ai monté une liste en 2008,
même si ce n'était pas une obligation,
une liste paritaire, autant de femmes
que d'hommes, avec des compétences
très diverses, des âges différents,
des responsabilités différentes,
des loisirs différents.
Et c'est comme ça, en fait,
qu'on a pu, au cours
de notre premier mandat,
trouver des médecins,
créer une maison de santé.
Alors, être maire, c'est presque
habiter avec les habitants,
c'est-à-dire qu’on est au cœur de
leurs moments de bonheur,
par exemple des mariages,
mais aussi leurs moments de difficultés,
ou quand un jeune
essaye de trouver un stage,
ou on a aussi la chance
de voir des porteurs de projets
qui veulent venir
s'installer dans nos communes.
Je pense qu'en fait,
être maire, c'est animer
cette cellule vivante qu’est une commune.
Mon job, c'est de faire en sorte
que ce corps vivant
qu'est la commune
soit en bonne santé,
reste en bonne santé.
Ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il se développe.
Les gens du cru y soient bien,
que les nouveaux habitants
y soient bien, que chacun
y trouve sa place et s'y épanouisse.